it's cookie season y'all that time of
year where you're making a whole lot of
cookies around the holiday season is
there anything more iconic than sugar
cookies we're going to give you our
tasty tested sugar cookie recipe
complete with everything you need to
have some darn good sugar cookies this
holiday season
[Music]
all right so let's get started so we're
going to make our dough first we're
going to use room temperature softened
butter listen that is not melted butter
melted butter is not the same and we go
we want a really pale color so that's
why we're using white sugar here and
this is a secret ingredient i know it
doesn't look like cream cheese but it is
cream cheese and this is going to give
us a little bit of like a savory flavor
and a little bit of tanginess as well
what we're trying to do is cream the
sugar and the butter together so if
you're feeling a lot of granules when
you stick your finger in there that's
not good we're trying to kind of almost
dissolve the sugar in the butter so
we're going to whip these together for
about five minutes they're going to be
much paler in color when we're done it's
going to be much fluffier so like you'll
see a visual change that's just whipping
in air to that butter and sugar
and then don't forget to scrape down
your bowl to make sure that you are
incorporating all the ingredients
equally
so now you can see we've got a really
great
creamed butter and sugar we're good to
go at this point we're gonna add one egg
two egg yolks
and our second secret ingredient is a
combo of extracts i think like vanilla
is pretty common in sugar cookies but we
are going to add a little bit of almond
extract as well a little bit goes a long
way it's a pretty powerful flavor but it
really adds something extra to these
sugar cookies and it's really delicious
like you're going to taste the
difference
and to that we just want to make sure
that all that liquid is well
incorporated into the butter and sugar
so once we have the liquids well
incorporated we're gonna add a little
bit of kosher salt here again not to
make it salty just to be a flavor
enhancer and balance out that sweetness
and so now we've got that in there we're
gonna add our all-purpose flour and next
goes in a little bit of baking powder
and this ingredient is our third little
secret ingredient for this recipe cream
of tartar cream of tartar is actually
what's left over in the barrel after
wine making and it's basically like just
an acidic ingredient so you're adding
this and this is going to help with a
few things it's going to give us like a
really cool texture in the end and it's
also going to prevent the cookies from
browning too much
so i'm going to fold in just to get it
started because there's a lot of flour
in here i don't want to make a huge mess
so i'm going to fold to get it started
finish incorporating it with the beaters
because it is a pretty dense mixture
there's a little bit of flowery bits
that aren't fully incorporated that's
fine
again to have like a really flaky and
snappy cookie you don't want to overwork
this mixture so you're kind of like just
incorporating the flour you don't want
to go much more than that
this dough is almost kind of similar to
like a pastry where you want to keep it
cold all the time
there's a lot of butter in here so if it
gets too greasy it's going to be really
really hard to work with and you're not
going to have really clear defined
shapes dough goes on with some cling
film and then you can use the cling film
to kind of like pull the pieces together
it's just like kind of sticky so this is
a really easy way to not make a huge
mess
so this is going to go into the fridge
and then we will roll it out in about
two hours
here are a few things you might need for
rolling out your cookies you need a
rolling pin or a wine bottle whatever
you have at your house and then
something to measure the thickness with
a ruler or our fourth little trick of
this video which we'll get to later if
you are making a lot of cookies or
you're like an avid baker they do have
these like kind of cool rubber rolling
pin thingies i don't know what you call
them like a rolling pin stoppers guards
maybe it really makes sure that you get
like that perfect quarter inch
but you have to have like the perfect
size rolling pins and you have to buy
them they're specialty so we're going to
show you a hack so the enemy of rolling
out anything is sticking to the surface
that you're working on so have a little
bit of flour nearby
as you remember we want to keep our
dough super cold so i'm going to work in
batches i'm going to put half of this
back in the fridge and only roll out
half at a time
all right so this is the trick that we
learned in culinary school you really
want an even quarter inch all throughout
to get the most even thickness you want
to press down on your dough like this
and it just kind of spreads it before
you want to get into rolling
every so often you wanna do like a
quarter turn and that's going to help
make sure that you have an even roll as
well as to ensure that it's not sticking
to the surface
this isn't like pie crust where you
really have to be careful about the
shape that you're making or whatever
this is just kind of a free-for-all
so i'm to a good place i'm not really
sure how thick mine is so how do i
measure this
you could use a ruler but you know
what's so annoying about this ruler is
like why does the zero start so far up
the ruler it's not so annoying but how
else can you measure
bottle caps i was looking all over the
kitchen for something else that's a
quarter inch i like to lay these around
the dough while i'm rolling out just to
make sure that all sides are that
perfect quarter inch
the other thing too is pour out that
extra bench flour and that's what we're
going to use to flour our cutters to
make sure the cutters aren't sticking
too much to the dough
so dip the cutter all the way in flour
dip off the excess and then
go ahead and then just give it a little
like jojo a little shimmy to make sure
that you've totally made contact with
the surface on the bottom and if you
have enough cutters what i like to do is
go ahead and put all the cutters down
and leave them and that makes sure that
nothing's pulling or tugging and you get
a really clean shape every time and now
you can start pulling them out
sometimes the cookie comes with the
cutter and sometimes it doesn't so i
like to kind of move around pull off the
excess put it off to one side
save that dough because you can use that
again
just be careful that you're not like
pulling or tugging at everything because
you really want the shape to be really
clean
and then look at that
so you can definitely reuse these scraps
what you want to do is get them back
into like a cohesive dough ball and then
put them back in the fridge they're
really warm after all that rolling and
working with them so get the cold one
out of the fridge and put that one back
in there for another like 20 minutes or
so so it can firm back up and there we
go
if you have some shapes that are smaller
than the other ones i would put those
off to the side so that if you need to
pull them early you can so that they
don't over bake
okay put these guys in the fridge you
put them in the oven now they're going
to spread way too much they're not going
to have a clean shape
they will come out super clean super
crisp as you can tell they're still very
pale and they haven't spread that much
yay go ahead and take them off and let
them cool completely on a drying rack
time to decorate
so we chose royal icing because it sets
a little bit harder if you're going to
be really crazy with decorating royal
icing is definitely the way to go so
despite its royal name royal icing is
pretty simple so all you really need is
some sifted powdered sugar you might
need a little bit of water
a bit of salt
an extract if you'd like it and egg
whites the thing about this is that we
will be consuming this so you really
want to make sure that you're buying
pasteurized egg whites so they're safe
for everyone to enjoy or you can use
meringue powder which is an egg white
substitute
we might need water it kind of depends
on what we're going for but first we're
going to add salt and a little bit of
vanilla for flavor i'm going to put this
off to the side so all the liquids we're
going to put on one side of the powdered
sugar and i'll show you why in a second
make sure to shake those egg whites
ahead of time and they go again making
sure that they're on one side of the
bowl
and so now i'm going to just work in
that one part of the bowl and just
slowly incorporate more of the powdered
sugar as i go that's gonna help make
sure that i have a really smooth icing
if you're trying to incorporate all that
powdered sugar at once it's just like a
little bit harder to work with and also
you probably will get some lumps royal
icing is all about consistency so
depending on how you want to
decorate yours there's kind of like two
consistencies that you're going for
there's a thicker consistency for more
of like lining things out or like
borders of things and then there's a
flood which is going to be just a
thinned out version and that water is
going to come in handy when we're
looking for that flood consistency
so we're starting here with a thicker
royal icing
we're also gonna add coloring to this
which will thin it out a little bit too
so air on the side of thicker when
you're getting started so we're gonna
separate the icing into a few different
bowls
if you're going to be doing a lot of
decorating or using a lot of different
colors it's probably worth it to double
or even triple this recipe go ahead and
put in your gel food colorings to get
really really bright colors
the thing that's cool about royal icing
is it sets right so like it'll set kind
of hard
even in this time while we're trying to
get everything set up you can already
see a little bit this kind of skin that
forms on top so you do want to work a
little bit quickly with royal icing or
else cover it with cling film and then
just to fix it just add a little bit of
water and stir
so now we can do one of two things with
this flood consistency flooding or
dipping
just go ahead and put the cookie dip it
in the icing make sure it's really well
coated
knock off any excess and then it's going
to kind of settle into the cookie and be
a really smooth and even shape
and then to flood what you got to do you
want like a thicker frosting and a
piping bag
and then go ahead and just trace the
outside with whatever color that you're
doing
and then you want to let this harden for
a little bit before you go to the next
step
but once it is hard all you need to do
is take that thinned out icing and you
can either spoon it in like i'm doing or
you can also put it in a piping bag and
pipe it in and then use the toothpick to
spread it out evenly that bit that you
piped in the beginning is dried so it
kind of acts as like a wall or a border
to ensure that all that icing is staying
inside
if you're going to put sprinkles on it
go ahead and put the sprinkles on when
it's wet but if you want to decorate
over that go ahead and let that set for
a good like 10 15 minutes or so and then
you can continue decorating on top of it
so kind of depends what look you're
going for
and as you can see like these dots are
kind of settling on top of it and not
really falling into that flood
and then if you want to decorate anymore
or put any other like toppings on top of
it you're going to have to layer more
icing on just to make sure that they
stick
there's like something magical about
this baking cookies it's kind of like
what gets you ready for the holidays
right like you know it's the holiday
season when it's time to bake the sugar
cookies and it's time to decorate them
and you know people really appreciate
the time and effort that goes into like
a home
decorated cookie and like does it look
like a professional no but that's not
the point you know the point is that you
took the time you did it you put in your
love and care there's like no better way
to bond with your friends and family
than doing something tangible diy and
creative like this go make some send us
your photos
have you ever seen a cuter cookie cutter
oh my god i can't say that three times
fast cuter cuddy cooker a cute have you
ever seen a cuter cookie cutter in your
life i can't it's so cute
[Music]